thank you all for joining us and i'm
delighted to welcome yale professor paul
bloom who's here to discuss his
fantastic new book the sweet spot we'll
be discussing finding the sweet spot of
pain pleasure and suffering he is the
brooks and suzanne reagan professor of
psychology and cognitive science at yale
university in this book paul addresses
questions such as why do some people
like horror movies
does unchosen suffering say the death of
a child make us more resilient what will
doubling your salary do to your
happiness
and why do we so often seek out pain and
emotional turmoil and there's many more
such questions in this book so i'll be
in discussion with paul for about half
an hour or so and then we'll be taking
your questions so as connor said please
go ahead and put them into the q a box
under your video screen and put in your
name if you'd like and again you can
also tweet to us using the hashtag iq
squared iq2
welcome paul so
first let me
just ask you what is the sweet spot
and why did you want to write about it
in this book
um thanks linda it's great to be talking
with you
i got into this book because i was
interested in certain puzzles strange
appetites people have you know we like
spicy foods or hot baths some of us go
to scary movies some of us listen to
songs that make us weep some people
enjoy bdsm
everybody enjoys some sort of pain and i
was really interested in in why
and and so i was going to write a book
on that called the pleasures of
suffering our pleasure is of pain but as
i wrote it
and started to write and start to read
what other people were talking about i
realized that there's another reason why
we seek out suffering and pain and
difficulty that's not for the purpose of
pleasure but for higher goals like
leading a meaningful life
or or or um or connection or spiritual
reasons or moral reasons
and my book says a lot of things but one
of the things is a defense of what i
could call motivational pluralism which
is humans have many many different
appetites
and one of the projects of being a
person then
is figuring out how to put them in the
right balance and to find a sweet spot
between pleasure and meaning and
morality and that's kind of how the book
got to title it also just seemed like a
nice and i i i i like the phrase it
seems to come up over and over again
and
you almost chose the book title the
pleasures of suffering but why did you
decide otherwise perhaps book sales
i like the pleasures of suffering the
problem with it was um it was incomplete
so it's true a lot of the suffering we
do
is for the purpose of um of pleasure
that's what bdsm is all about it's just
it's people enjoy it that's where people
go to go to scary movies they enjoy it
they have fun for us oh i'm sorry i'm
sorry and there may be a a sort of
language difference here um um it's
sadomasochistic behavior sadomasochistic
sex it includes everything from heavy
duty
sadomasochism the experience of real
pain but it also includes um reading a
book like 50 shades of gray or watching
more like 50 shades away where you enjoy
it vicariously
and that was that so and that's all
pleasure
but then
i started thinking about other things
like um
training for a marathon
or uh starting a business writing a book
raising children i find raising children
is for me a wonderful example of
something which people do
they usually don't regret it they say
it's a tremendous significance but it's
hard
it involves anxiety and struggle and
difficulty people know it's going to be
hard
and i think the difficulty is part and
parcel of why it's so valuable but i
wouldn't call that pleasure in any
simple sense
you write that the idea we hope to make
it through life unscathed is not quite
complete as a theory of a good life so
in the book you write that under the
right circumstances and in the right
doses physical and emotional pain
difficulty failure and loss are exactly
what we're looking for so tell me why
you're right that nobody is immune to
the lure of suffering
so
the last part is
is an empirical observation of the world
i've never met somebody who one way or
another didn't seek out pain
yeah and it differs your your mileage
may vary some people like to run
others like to go to movies that that
make them scream that just terrify them
very upsetting um some like to indulge
in in masochistic fantasies of what
happens when their life goes badly some
people you know train for for from
difficult physical pursuits they go on
long they travel to difficult places
they go they go camping you know giving
up hot showers and everything and for
all of these things the people say yeah
i know it hurts i know this is going to
be hard
but that's part and parcel what makes it
important
and you write about two forms of chosen
suffering so we mentioned there the
experience of a marathon that gives
pleasure
and secondly
the part that is also um
i think probably not discussed as much
is that something like a marathon could
be part of a life well-lived so just
tell me about the importance of chosen
suffering for for something like that
that's right that's
an important thing to to talk about
right away i wrote um in the wall street
journal summary of my book a couple
weeks back and right away i got a very
angry letter from somebody who says i
live my whole life in chronic pain
the terrible thing who are you to tell
me this is valuable what do you know
and i pointed out you're right
i'm not saying that bad stuff that
happens to you is something we should
welcome
chronic pain the death of a child
a violent assault
that's bad stuff which happens to people
and i think we could talk about how
resilient people are and the stories
people tell
but that's not what i'm arguing for i'm
arguing for the suffering we choose
and the suffering we choose
could come in roughly two flavors though
there's cases which sort of overlap so
one flavor is we really seek out the
suffering we seek out the pain you know
so so i'm gonna eat some really spicy
food and i know it's hot i know it's
gonna burn my mouth and make me sweat
and make me gasp but i don't like it i'm
gonna go to a hot bath that's really
gonna fry me up uh sauna or whatever and
but we see a payoff at the end we see
some pleasure at the end so that's one
sort
a second sword is a bit more complicated
you somebody might say look i want to
train for a marathon i'm out of shape i
train for a marathon when you say that
you know you're not looking forward to
blisters you're not looking forward to
muscle aches and disappointment and
maybe failure
but if if you didn't know it was
difficult if it wasn't hard
it would have no value to you
so we so it's not that it's not that we
say i want to do really unpleasant
difficult experiences uh rather some of
the time it's i want to do things which
are meaningful and important and i know
those involve difficult experiences
so tell me more about benign masochism
the term that you use in the book it's a
lovely lovely term uh thought of by paul
rosin um and
he the benign part is important these
are not cases where people mutilate
themselves are given themselves
excruciating agony it's little things
it's you know you have a sprained ankle
and you press on it a bit
you have a sword tooth and you poke it
with your tongue
um you you listen to a song there's a
really sad song and you're kind of in a
bad one you listen to that adele always
does it for me and you kind of get a
little bit of sadness
you you sulk you you nurture old wounds
you through choice you put yourself in a
bad space either physically or
emotionally
and
a large part of my book the sort of
first half says what's up with this why
are we doing this and i think there's
different explanations one of which is
contrast this is the simplest one which
is sometimes we play with pain to give
ourselves greater pleasure in the future
you might put some really spicy foods in
your mouth and then you drink some cool
beer and you feel great you might go
into a hot sauna then dive into a cool
lake you might see a movie where all
these terrible things happen
but then
the hero gets revenge at the end and all
is good and so we play with contrast so
that's one thing going on in benign
masochism
another thing just to put it on the
table
is um that we we um we like to sometimes
escape from ourselves escape from our
consciousness
sometimes
being a person with our
self-consciousness and our our guilt and
our shame and our worries
is oppressive
certain sharp experiences pull us away
from this
you know
i tell in my book the first time i ever
did a brazilian jiu jitsu and i was a
sparring i was rolling with somebody and
this person was much stronger and much
younger than me like everyone else in
the gym
and for three minutes he basically
repeatedly tried to pull my head off of
my body and twist my arms off and in
some way it was painful and difficult
and kind of scary
but i realized afterwards that during
that time i thought of nothing else
my mind was clear i wasn't thinking how
am i looking i hope my kids are okay
that i was and some things like bdsm
sorry sadomasochism
rigorous exercise
intense focus
will do that you'll lose yourself and
there's a lot of to be said about that
want to explore some of this um
in our discussion uh but i want you to
first tell the audience the story of the
twilight zone episode that captures this
idea that
this omnipotence is boring
yeah this is this i i saw this when i
was when i was a kid original twilight
zone and that this story and i think
there's a real wisdom in it the story is
there's a terrible mobster and he dies
and he wakes up
and he's in a lovely hotel room you know
beautiful view of the river this and
and he discovers and he has an angel
guide and the guide says you can do
whatever you want and the guy says wow i
didn't expect this when i died i thought
i was a bad person and says yeah so he
gets all the sex he wants and the power
and he buys stuff and everything comes
to him easy he plays poker with his
buddies and wins everything again and
again and again
and he starts to go crazy and he starts
and he says this is this is this is
horrible and he finally says to the guy
i've i have enough of heaven
i want to go to the other place and the
guide says why do you think this is
heaven this is the other place and one
version of hell
would be you get what you want all the
time and it would strip
every activity of joy and it's
complicated you and i decide to play
poker together i'm looking forward to it
and
i don't want to lose i want to win you
want to win
but
if we knew we were going to win we
wouldn't bother playing too boring
the idea of risk and anxiety and a
possibility of loss is just integral to
these sort of activities
so tell me about how the brain grades on
a curve
so
and
that means the secret to happiness
may be unhappiness as you said out in
your book
so this goes back to the idea of
contrast um
we don't process experiences
in terms of
of absolutes you know the temperature
water feels like when you stick your
hand into that depends a lot on what the
air temperature here is and what
temperature it used to be
um
you know something and and it's the same
with experiences like pain and pleasure
so something and there's they've done
laboratory experiments and something
that's kind of mildly unpleasant
if you were expecting it to be much
worse could actually feel pleasant and
it's true more abstractly you lose ten
dollars in a game and that's pretty bad
but if you thought you're going to lose
100 that's good news
and so we play with contrast and one of
the ways we play with this is if you
have some negative experiences and then
you have sort of a neutral experience
coming right afterwards the neutral gets
boosts boosted by the comparison of the
negative
and and i think we play with this a lot
and it's sort of
putting ourselves in mild painful
experience are difficult experiences for
the release um it all breaks down to the
silly joke my dad told me when i was a
kid about the guy who bangs his head
against the wall and she said why are
you doing that he says it feels so good
when i stop
and you know it's a dumb joke but to
some extent someone does something we do
some of this in our everyday life
and
you know there's all sorts of things
that go on for instance when we choose
to go for a lengthy hike or um or or
camping there's a feeling of mastery
there's connection with nature but also
there's the fact that when it's over we
feel so good
and we look back and say look what i did
thank goodness this in the past but look
what i did i feel great about it
so staying on the theme of happiness for
experienced happiness you cite a study
that shows that money matters only up to
about 89 000 so that's about sixty six
thousand pounds
but when it comes to life satisfaction
there's no leveling off so tell me about
this contrast
yeah um this is some work by uh danny
kahneman brilliant psychologist who who
won the nobel prize for it and he points
out that when we talk about happiness
everybody says i want to be happy but
happiness means at least to one of two
things
one thing is your experienced happiness
like so every you know i give you an uh
an iphone app and then it beeps every um
every once in a while and then when it
beeps you say how happy you are
like oh i'm eight out of ten i'm seven
out of ten i'm nine out of ten and then
i can figure out how happy you are on
average for your whole life and that's
your experience happiness another way
though is i could ask you linda how
happy are you just take a few minutes
and think a scale of one to ten or how
good is your life give me the answer
just think about things and these
answers correlate but they're kind of
different one answer is your day-to-day
pleasures the first one the second
answer is your contemplative feeling
about how well your life is going
and and we could argue and i think it's
a very good argument which one should we
try to maximize
but there's been studies about relation
from money to these and the argument is
that day-to-day pleasures
money putting money makes people happier
it's it's it's you know if anybody ever
told you the opposite they're wrong
money is a great predictor of happiness
of any sort
um
richer people are happier than poorer
people richer countries are have happier
citizens and poorer countries and it's
not a surprise money buys you you know
health access to health care it buys you
safety it buys you a good schooling for
your kids
freedom from exploitation time with your
friends and you know cool stuff
but for experience it kind of
at a certain point it doesn't matter if
you have more the original studies said
about 80 000 american dollars done a
little while ago let's say you know
uh 100 000 pounds or something
um but for your but for your your
uh reflective remembered happiness the
sky is the limit there's diminishing
returns and so you wonder what's the
difference
and one answer is status
so if i say linda how's your life going
one of the things you were thinking like
okay am i well fed am i safe am i sick
how many people i love doing but then
you also say how am i doing relative to
everybody else
and if you say i'm making a lot more
money than this guy i'm talking to
that's pretty good and then that boosts
up your happiness to sort of we get very
status oriented and comparative
and
it's absolutely fascinating um the uh i
think there's quite a lot of uh
happiness as a relative concept you know
keeping up with the joneses tends to
make you a bit unhappy and so um
i can see questions beginning to come in
please do continue to submit them
and we will get to those up very shortly
but before we do um paul i want to
talk to you about meaning so before we
go into some of the concepts in your
book i just have one question for you um
is it the case that everyone over the
age of 40 has a midlife crisis
no i wouldn't think so
why why do you ask have people been
talking about me
well people talk about uh meaning um i
think that's um you know when you start
thinking about those questions so i
think that's where um
uh that occurred to me so you relay a
study in the book where people were
asked are you a giver or a taker
givers have more meaning in their lives
but takers have more happiness
so what do the responses mean
it's really interesting and it goes back
to ideopluralism and there's more than
one way
to live your life there's more than one
thing to focus on and some of it you
know i don't want to be be too glib
about answering your midlife crisis
question um david brooks has a very
interesting book called the second
mountain where he points out for a lot
of people and this is not cross-cultural
this is kind of a something you know in
in in western countries but and and i
think there's just a group of people
there but sometimes people say they
strive for
for pleasures for happiness then they
get to a certain point and they say well
okay
let me go for something deeper now
something more uh you know
you go from the sort of
virtues that you'd want on your cv on
your resume to the virtues you wanted
your eulogy
when you know people when you're dead
and people talking to you
um
and to get a sense of this of the
different priorities people have
there's a lovely study by roy baumeister
and his colleagues and what they did was
they asked people a bunch of different
questions and one question to ask people
was like how happy are you standard
question
other question is how much meaning do
you have in your life how you know how
meaningful is your life now one thing i
always have to stress here is these
answers are correlated
so you have a lot of people which are
high in one and zero and other
but they tend to go together so if you
tell me you have a meaningful life you
could just also have a happy life
but now let's look at people who go for
one versus the other
and you're exactly right
people there's a kind of a different
profile
happiness is associated with good health
with money
and um and associated with a relatively
easy life
low stress low anxiety low difficulty
meaning is less associated with
happiness less associated with money and
some studies negatively associated money
and also associated with difficulty and
struggle
and and interacting with people and
maybe helping people but it's hard
and this shows up all over the place
there was a study of two million people
looking at the jobs
they they had and asking how meaningful
is your job
and it turns out the jobs that are most
meaningful number one was being a member
of clergy
being a minister or a priest a rabbi or
whatever
social worker
educator being a member to military
medical professional and a lot of these
jobs on the top of the list most
meaningful they don't pay well
they're low status
and they're tough
but they're meaningful
and there's a lot of other jobs which i
think have a lot of pleasure give you a
lot of money
but they do lack meaning
and
you write about suffering as
a part of meaning in the book um
so you talk about the movie the matrix i
have to say i've watched the matrix i am
the computer designed world and tell us
that story and why that captures this so
well for you because after reading your
book i now get that scene
well i tell a story i tell an origin
story that was told in the matrix if you
haven't if you haven't seen the movie
just skip over this part but um but uh
where agent smith is explaining
to um to i think the morpheus
and his marcus um how the world came to
be and and because the idea is the world
is is you know a
a computer simulation that most of us
live in the story animation the classic
the classic philosophical
story like that that they they grew from
he said we once tried to make you a
paradise
that every need was satisfied
and it um and it broke you didn't
survive
you need suffering and pain you need
struggle or else it doesn't work
and i like the matrix story can i tell
one other quick story it's it's it's
it's not for me it's from alan watts uh
the guy who brought a zen to the west
and he tells the story of um you go to
sleep
and you find yourself having a lucid
dream you could dream whatever you want
it says for 90 years 90 years of
experience whatever you want he said you
would have the best time ever
sex and love and adventure and great
food and parties and everything like
that
and then you you wake up you live your
day and you go to sleep again and there
again you have another
you know 90 years he says
you wouldn't do the same thing over
again you say well let's make things
difficult let's throw some some failure
let's let's do it because sometimes you
try something you lose sometimes you
think it's easy it's going to be hard
you put in struggle and difficulty and
complexity and then the punchline is he
says maybe this is the world you're
living now
that this world that that contains all
of these you think you might want the
first world but this is the world you
want and this is the world you have
yeah now that's a great story that you
have in the book in fact you have so
many great stories in the book i'm i'm
glad them that you were able to discuss
that one you also have some fantastic
quotes and i'm going to quote um your
book where you quote u.s supreme court
chief justice john roberts speech where
he says
and this is his commencement speech or
graduation um at a university so he in
his speeches he said i wish you bad luck
again from time to time so that you will
be conscious of the role of chance in
life and understand that your success is
not completely deserved and that the
failure of others
is not completely deserved either
so tell me about this quote and that and
i think
in your chapter on on suffering
you make uh
you do make a distinction between the
chosen suffering um that we discussed
before
so be great to come back to that and
think about um the speech and and what
we've been discussing
i think you're
you're right i think there's a great big
difference between the theme of my book
which is the suffering we choose and how
this gives both pleasure and meaning
and bad stuff that happens to us the
stuff that john roberts is talking about
and i quote him and i quote him with
respect it's a nice summary of an idea
i'm not sure he's right
i'm not sure there's some data
suggesting that people who have
experienced
no suffering at all no bad things has
ever happened sometimes you sometimes
people make the age of 30 40 and they're
unscathed they've never been assaulted
nobody they they love has died they've
never had a mass a failure of any sort
and those people there's some evidence
that they have low pain tolerance
that they tend to catastrophize
um that are less kind
and that that some suffering is needed
to get through the world
but i don't think you need that much and
i think the idea that uh nietzsche then
famous nietzsche quote uh what doesn't
kill us makes us stronger is one of the
stupidest things a smart philosopher
ever said because sometimes what doesn't
kill us really messes us up
you know it could it could give us ptsd
it could traumatize us it could make us
meaner and harder
i don't i think
i just think that life is full of
suffering enough
and the claim that oh you all need more
i i actually don't don't buy it
and
i think there's part of it which is
actually cruel
in a sense that
if you tell me something bad has
happened to you
um i'm not sure i want to come back and
say such an opportunity for growth
you're so lucky this bad thing is
happening this will make you better
i think a more realistic
response is to remind you that most
people are really resilient most people
are resilience is the rules ptsd
post-traumatic stress or that's
exception
you will get over this but i don't have
to tell you you better improve
most people don't
most people get over most people survive
and
you also quote shakespeare you really do
have such a wide range in the book paul
i've just gone from john roberts to
shakespeare you quote shakespeare in
your book um there's nothing either good
or bad but thinking makes it so
so you give that quote in the context of
saying there's something even greater in
terms of a greater truth about the good
life so tell me what that is
i like that quote because it applies to
many things i think it particularly
applies to um what we were talking about
before about contrast and benign
masochism
so
you know imagine you all of your heart
is pounding you can't breathe you're
soaked with sweat
is that a good experience or a bad
experience well if it's happening to you
right now would it be a bad experience
you say i'm having a heart attack this
is horrible
on the other hand if you're finishing
off a marathon it could be a glorious
experience
suppose you're scared out of your wits
well
is it because there's an intruder in
your house
or is it because you're in a haunted
house having a good time and so on and
so forth are feelings physical and
emotional
aren't in themselves good or bad
but thinking makes them so how we
construe things makes a huge difference
in our experiences
fascinating
um
in the acknowledgments you thank someone
for nearly persuading you that the whole
idea of this book is deeply confused
after you had finished writing it
dare i ask what he said to nearly
persuade you yeah this is my my good
friend uh
my ex-friend whenever i talk about him
uh he doesn't want to be talked about so
so but no uh my good friend and if you
look at it at my book i cite his
research more than anybody else he does
these brilliant studies these clever
brilliant studies
and he is a hedonist he thinks my
motivational pluralism is silly he
thinks in the end
all there is is pleasure and older is
worth doing is maximizing pleasure
and it was you know i recommend
everybody writing a book to get
themselves a dan gilbert some really
smart person who thinks they're so wrong
and um and and i and i wrestle with his
ideas through the book and you know
obviously i'm not convinced
i think that that the desire for meaning
and the desire for pleasure desire to be
a good person which we haven't spoken
about are genuinely different
they're different parts of the brain
they vary in different ways for
different people
they compel us in different ways and
they clash with one another
but a smart hedonist
will always argue well you think you try
to you know you think you try to make
things fair because you care about
fairness but really what you want is the
buzz
that you know you get from doing a good
thing or an applause that people give
you
and you know you read the book you see i
am not convinced but uh but it's it's
it's always good to have such a a sharp
critic by your side
indeed you argue in the book that a life
well-lived is more than a life of
pleasure it involves moral goodness and
meaningful pursuits
as well as other things so just tell me
more about it
um
so
in some way this is not this is not a
psychological claim it's a judgment
claim
it's you know i can't say oh studies
from my lab have shown you're making a
big mistake you just try to be happy it
doesn't it doesn't work that way it's
fundamentally
a moral claim about how we should live
and i'll tell you one more story uh
which is which i think which was
intended to illustrate this point it's
by the philosopher robert nozick
and nozick imagines an experience
machine and now we're actually going
back to the matrix of it where they plug
you into a machine and for the rest of
your life you just lie on a bed the rest
of your natural life and you have the
experience of the best life
of success and love and purpose
but of course it's just all a dream it
just plugged in
uh and he asked would you want to get
plugged into the machine and
a lot of people including him including
me say no
and we say no
because we don't just want to have the
experience of doing things we want to do
things
we say no because we want to make the
world a better place not just think we
made the world a better place
we say no because if we plug ourselves
into a machine we're abandoning
everybody we love and i couldn't bear to
do it even though while i'm in the
machine of course i never think of that
and to the extent you're pulled by this
to the extent you sort of say yeah those
other things matter too
you're also a motivational pluralist
absolutely fascinating a reminder i see
the questions coming in i'm going to
turn to the questions in just a moment
so please if you'd like to ask paul
question put it into the q a box under
your video screen if you'd like to tweet
at us use the hashtag iq2 so paul before
i turn to the question i want to come
back to your own experience of being in
a flow state so you talked about
training for a marathon you're writing
the book about learning to code tell me
how you realized you wanted to spend
more of your life in the state of flow
and why made you happier and more
fulfilled
yeah for me the catalyst was reading um
uh mihaly chick sent me high's book flow
and i read this uh uh later in my life
but it had this tremendous influence on
me and he he describes float and
suddenly he passed away a couple weeks
ago actually after his wonderful life
but he describes what a flow state is
and and the best definition for me is a
flow state is between
you're not bored
you're not anxious you're in this sort
of sweet spot
and um and you lose it's you're so
immersed you lose track of time you
don't forget to eat if you get to pick
up the kids you're just totally lost in
it and in this book he describes um how
trained athletes and dancers and
musicians and artists and and writers
find themselves in flow states sometimes
for hours and hours at a time while some
people never get into flow states
because it's difficult to get into flow
state it's a lot easier to watch tv or
check your email or go on twitter
but but um but he made such a compelling
case
that and i thought about this and as i
wrote this book i thought about it more
that i'm trying to get more of that into
my life
and and trying to to shift away from
things oh that'll be fun
that'll satisfy my immediate appetites
and think about things is it the right
level of difficulty that i could lose
myself in it
and i think that sort of thing is
extremely rewarding you know i'd like to
be able to buy my book but if you only
buy one book uh i buy flo i think this
floats great
okay you'd need to buy you need to buy
paul's book
there's a tab
on your screen
and can never have too many books but um
but really um you know it's it's really
a fantastic book and so many great
stories and insights and so i really do
hope you pick up a copy of the book and
um i'm going to now turn to uh audience
questions and they're just coming in
i'll get you as many as i can the first
one is from sarah who asks do you think
we live in a society that tells us to
avoid pain to our detriment people often
say kids are too protected from pain
i think i think sarah raises a good
point um i mean there are a lot of
societies
and they differ in all sorts of ways
but
i think
we tend to live in a society that kind
of values hedonism and values pleasure
and fun
maybe a bit too much
and
one way this is manifested is in the
biggest
revolution in our lives which has
happened over the last 10 20 years which
is social media and streaming services
and so on which is
you go through your life with constant
prodding
of don't try don't work don't struggle
stick your face next to the screen
and pass out
you know watch a show
watch youtube videos
and i'm sensitive because i'm very
vulnerable to this i can you know i'm
having problems sleeping and i pick up
my phone and on facebook and videos
start showing up and then hours gone by
and i've just lost it
and um
you know the way i like to think about
it is um
the the i think the ceo of netflix once
boasted that he wasn't competing with
other streaming services he's competing
with sleep
and i think facebook and twitter and
alike aren't competing with each other
they're competing with life
and they are offering you a simple easy
pleasure and highly incentivizing you to
do it
and while you know i don't want to sound
like somebody's dad but you should go
outside and and go for a run you should
lift some weights read a russian novel
you know
have kids do do tough stuff
so yeah i do think in some way there's a
conspiracy against
the right sort of suffering in our world
the next questions come from uh raw who
asks what is the function of pain from a
psychological perspective i've heard is
to tell the brain there's something
wrong is that accurate
that is accurate that is accurate so
pain serves a clear evolutionary purpose
which is it does um so you know you take
you an animal
human touches a cactus it hurts like
hell the arm is throbbing in agony and
there's two things here one is
because it was bad you don't touch the
cactus anymore a critical learning
experience and also now the hand is
injured and it hurts if you keep it safe
you let it heal
without pain
people would be lost you might think
pain is bad and a lot of pain as in
chronic pain is unnecessary and we do
and of course there's an enormous
industry trying to quell
pains we don't do us any good
but if you strip pain from somebody
they'd be in deep trouble and we know
that because there's unfortunate people
who are born without the capacity to
feel pain
and those people do very badly
they they end up getting burnt and
scarred
they don't treat their bodies properly
they don't protect limbs right often
they die quite young because of of
of the number of injuries they sustain
so on the whole
darwin makes it that pleasure is what
draws you to what you should do pain
pulls you away from what you shouldn't
do
and my book is about exceptions my book
is about cases where pain is supposed to
be bad but it can be it can be in the
right circumstances good
but the but the evolutionary account
given is i think precisely right
thank you next question is one thing
i've always wondered is there a
difference between happiness and
fulfillment in your view
people use the terms in all sorts of
different ways and so i'm not gonna say
oh absolutely and we've shown that there
is because it depends you can use them
that they mean the same thing
but maybe one way to answer this is i
think there's very different notions
that really worth keeping apart
and we could call one of them happiness
another one fulfillment and happiness is
basically how much fun you're having how
much pleasure you're having
you know you're sitting you're lying in
a in a nice swimming pool and it's sunny
outside and you're you know you're
you're kind of napping and and when you
get up you have a pina colada and i say
how you doing i'm pretty happy you say
but
suppose you do this over and over again
and that's kind of your life
you might say i'm pretty happy we're not
very fulfilled i'm not very satisfied i
think i think for happiness resonates
more to pleasure fulfillment more with
meaning and purpose she could be high in
one and low and other
you can also have i was talking to a
friend of mine last night you always
have a life where you feel this is a
valuable life a purpose and meaning
day-to-day kind of sucks
and
you know a very interesting experience
of raising children and a lot of people
with young children really young
children or children with different
disabilities or teenagers or you know
maybe maybe old children um kind of find
it hard
and and are they happy
no my kids are driving me nuts i murder
for a good night's sleep you know i wish
i had some some better child care i wish
the house is so dirty
but are you fulfilled yes
so you do get this difference
next question coming in paul the
question is sometimes we know we should
embrace some pain but we're scared of
being vulnerable how do we overcome that
and uh asking for a friend was the last
part of that
always always asking for a friend
well
everybody has a sort of level of pain
and suffering that's acceptable
um
i like scary movies sometimes i'll go to
sometimes i'll scare the pants off me
and i'll get get a
pleasure from it um but if they were too
scary it'd just be upsetting and really
unpleasant
i got my level
um
you know i kind of like to go for uh a
good run sometimes would i run an
ironman triathlon no it'd kill me
you know so and so
i think
um
it's not always a matter of saying oh
you know i'm a bit trepidatious but i'm
gonna i should jump in how could get us
to jump in maybe you're reasonably
cautious
i think people should sort of there's a
sort of know thyself thing here which is
that but even when it comes to all these
pleasures
everything from scary movies to spicy
foods to to sadomasochistic sex
it's really good to know what your
limits are
everybody has different limits
and different things they like even says
something as simple as how hot do you
want your bath how spicy do you want
your curry
and um
and it's not a matter of oh just hit the
maximum i'm sure it'll work out some
people it's too much so so
i guess the idea would be i'm going to
cautious or just dip a toe in
try it then try to ratchet things up you
know i don't know try try the two-star
chili before trying the three star chili
and then see what you like find your
sweet spot that way
i think that's good advice when it comes
to chili's in particular
this question
is from tom and derbyshire very
interesting that the job market seems to
be inverted in terms of meaning
do you think this is something we can
collectively change
it's a really good question and and it
actually um
i mean my answer is i don't know i mean
the the
what gets
the forces that cause some jobs to be
priced and pay well
are often very different from from
considerations of either the value of
the job or the meaningfulness of the job
and so on in some way it's not
bad
that meaningful jobs
don't pay that well because they're
meaningful that's a good thing about it
you know maybe you should give people a
lot of money to for jobs that are not
meaningful because then they have the
money and then they could get meetings
some other way
um
there's
the the issue of jobs and meaning is
very urgent these days um there's
something in the in the united states
they're calling the great resignation or
the great quit i don't know is it there
as well it is yes
and you know a lot of people are not
going back to work
and um and a lot of this is because well
a lot of it because people's jobs are
are unrewarding and unsatisfying um
the the sociologist david graver called
talks about [ __ ] jobs which are jobs
and there's sometimes there's sort of
middle management jobs which just
they're doing nothing you're just
shuffling papers around it's not even
that they're terrible they just provide
no meaning because they have no impact
on the world
and so
if if we could work to eliminate jobs
that do no good
if we could work to properly you know
make it make rewarding
jobs um
that that uh that that that are needed
and fix up some some really gross
imbalances in what people are paid for i
think that that would be a good thing i
also think by the way that sometimes
people get jobs wrong
and what they think is oh the job i want
should be easy well paid high status and
easy
but it's a recipe for boredom
um i think the idea of going for
challenging jobs and jobs that push you
is really valuable
and and i'll end on a kind of a zen
thing which is there's a zen
idea that any activity any job can be
made meaningful in the hands of the
right person cleaning toilets washing
dishes and everything uh can can be
given meaning and i you and i've seen
this i've seen people do jobs which
other people view as menial and they
think this is this is important and they
seek out the importance in it and i've
also seen the flip side i'm a you know
i'm a tenured professor and i think this
job is just full of immense
possibilities and opportunities
but in the last two years i've had three
friends quit 10-year people at top
universities quit and they say this
isn't doing anything for me i'm deeply
unsatisfied and i want to do something
else
so you're you know people are different
in how they respond to different
circumstances
the next question starts off with thanks
thanks paul a great talk the question is
how do we know that chosen suffering is
going to lead to long-term pleasure
um
we know it not so much from sort of
specific laboratory studies or or
experiments
but from observing uh observing
activities that people themselves engage
in
so um so we know for instance that
there's a pleasure and a satisfaction to
sustained effort
and you know everything from doing
crossword puzzles i like doing crossword
puzzles and i like the idea that i'm
sort of struggling with crossword
puzzles that i do it all the way to
running marathons to triathlons to
writing books to
opening a business that that people will
tell you
that what what matters the most to them
are things that involve struggle and
difficulty
so it's something we see not so much
in experimental laboratories but played
out in the real world
i mean to put it another way if you went
up to somebody and said you know
what gives you the most satisfaction and
pleasure and joy
it's very likely it'll answer you with
something that involves difficulty and
work and struggle
oh i can't hear you
i can't
i still can't hear you
could somebody tell us whether it's my
problem or linda's
i'm uh let me know there we go that's
right i moved i moved to speak maybe
that was my fault no no it's probably my
fault so the next question is do you
have any thoughts on drugs that induce
pleasure
like mdma do you think these would be
valuable to be explored more
um yeah i'm i'm enough of a
motivational plural thing pleasure is
good
mdna mdma is is good uh you know
a nice whiskey uh you know uh i'm in
toronto now where marijuana is legalized
and and it seems the whole city isn't a
cloud of pot
um and i think these things are good as
far as it goes
if they are indulged in enough um so
much that they rob you of everything
else in life and they're sort of a
cliche of the stoner on the sofa who the
rest of his life he's just smoking pot
and getting high
um then i think it's tragic
but uh and
but but drugs that give you pleasure as
long as they have the right place in
your life and putting aside any other
side effects that that's all to the good
there's nothing wrong nothing wrong with
being happy
and then you also get to the case where
and this i don't know this wasn't a
question but you get the antidepressants
and drugs that uh that are done to deal
with clinical conditions
and there um
and there i think that are very valuable
i don't think people can people find it
very hard to do even meaningful
difficult things when they're depressed
or anxious so taking the drugs to pull
you out and making a more full person i
think has tremendous value
the next question paul there is a big
mental health crisis among young men
right now why do you think that is
um
there are actually several different
mental health crises young different
people my answer to everything regarding
mental health for the last two years is
covet
so so the the pandemic
has had caused terrible disruptions and
terrible effects on depression and
anxiety there's a lot of debate
over over um the extent to this and
where it happens and who it happens to
but covet has definitely taken its toll
there are other factors in the united
states but i'm not sure elsewhere
there are what angus dieden calls deaths
of despair
and
these are actually uh tend to be
localized in men
but not young men men in their 50s and a
bit older
who who have seemed to have an epidemic
of suicide a lot of it is related to
opioid addiction
and then there's a general fact and i
this is not this is not recent um this
has probably been a problem for as long
as there's been people but but
young people often struggle with meaning
and and and they you know and a lack of
fulfillment and i don't i want to be
sort of cautious here because i don't
think the evidence is strong this is
speculation but i think for a lot of
young people and maybe young men
they feel kind of at a loss
they feel they don't have they might
have some degree of material wealth
particularly in the good society has
some sort of welfare system but their
lives lack meaning
um
and
you know the solution to this one
solution of this is to pick up a cause
hopefully a good cause
and these things give meaning i i quote
um early in the book uh greta thundberg
the young climate activist he had this
tweet and said basically i can't
remember it off my heart basically he
said um said i was just miserable at
home doing nothing
without anything
and then i i discovered this cause and
it infused my life with meaning and now
i am transformed and that is very very
typical
and we have time i'm going to get to i
think two more questions paul in the
time that we have remaining we just had
fantastic questions throughout um so
thank you all for sending those in i'm
sorry if we couldn't get to all of them
um so the penultimate question for you
is are you someone who subscribes to the
idea that the decline of religion has
led to people losing meaning in their
lives and sarah asked that
yes
i'm i'll say this saying that
just before people think whoa where am i
coming from that i am a secular atheist
i i don't believe any of any of the
stuff but i'm very interested in
religion
and
religion is plainly a source of meaning
for many people
and this brings us back to unchosen
suffering
where
as a secular atheist if something bad
happens to me i just that that's bad
something bad happened to me uh you know
my somebody i love dies i lose my job my
house burns down that just is
but religion
provides narratives
and it may i might say well god was
testing me or everything happens for a
reason i'm sure this will come out
better in the end
and religion provides a lot of
narratives to to fill your life
with meaning and i think that could have
a huge a huge benefit for many people i
mean one
i said before that poor countries people
have lives of less meaning
of more meaning than rich countries
one reason for this is poor countries
are more religious
than rich countries
so yeah there's a lot to that claim
[Music]
and then the final question uh paul um
going back to fear of pain i not risking
for fear of pain there are many people
who are incapable of loving out of fear
of getting hurt
what then aside from a good
psychologist
which
would be your answer to that
um
i my answer is a good is a good
psychologist
i mean and and
you know
there's all sorts of reasons why people
are are leery of relationships and to
some extent
it connects to what we're talking about
here which is
meaning
i talked about having kids but actually
romantic relationships are a really good
example of what is an end a meaningful
and i think hard pursuit
you know
one night stands flirting
the initial spark of a relationship
could be nothing but pleasure and joy
but sustaining a relationship is fraught
with risk
and disappointment and struggle
um you know nobody who's been in
relation with somebody for a year
has always had good times with them
and
and i think
but i think that and i'm not saying
anything new here that this is one of
the most important pursuits we could
have there's a line from sigmund freud
he's asked what's the value now it turns
out he didn't actually say this but it's
a good line he says
love and work
a healthy mind has solved the problems
of love and work where work refers to a
lot of we're talking here sustained
activity and difficult projects and love
is relationships with your with your
kids with your your brothers and sisters
your friends and and with romantic
partners and and
whoever wrote that i mean i i don't have
any more to say than finding good people
to a good person to talk with
to work you through this and get you
prepared to go on that next step is
indispensable
and really important
it's been absolutely fantastic paul
before we let you go
what would you like our audience to take
away from your work on the sweet spot
what are the kinds of things you want
them to to go away and to think about
um
perhaps they could dive into your debate
with the hedonists
yes
i guess i guess a couple i guess a
couple of things one thing would be um
to sort of think a little bit about the
role of pain and suffering and
difficulty and effort in a life well
lived
maybe ask yourself if you don't if you
haven't chosen any of these things maybe
you give them a shot
and your book has a lot of stories and
examples of this and then the other one
is more theoretical actually i'm you
know i'm a research psychologist uh i'm
it's nice it's nice to try to help
people and give advice and i don't
resist the temptation but i'm really
interested in how the mind works and to
take seriously the idea
uh
that humans are complicated
that uh we we are very quick to
denigrate ourselves say oh all we want
is pleasure we only want to get pleasure
avoid pain simple as that but it's not
it's much richer it's the religious
people have it more right than a lot of
my psychologist colleagues um we want
many things we want pleasure sure but we
also want meaning we want morality
sometimes you want truth sometimes you
want beauty
it's it's a lot of things life is
interesting
so that's it
great great takeaways um and your book
is absolutely fascinating thank you so
much
we there's we talked about a lot of uh
concepts but there's so much more in the
book especially around stories and
details and studies i mean pain
happiness meaning um i i'm astounded at
how much ground you've actually covered
and also i would just tell the audience
you can buy the book using the tab on
your screen it's very accessibly written
and a real pleasure to read so a huge
thanks to paul bloom for spending the
time with us to uh to share the insights
from his book and
um it's been just an absolutely
fascinating hour um so again please go
buy his book the sweet spot i urge you
all to pick up a copy you won't regret
it um and with that i'm going to thank
you all for joining us for this
intelligent squared plus event